notice from the records and information
security administration the following
documentation has been flagged as
compromised by a CP 2786 effects due to
the nature of this anomaly this has been
deemed safe for reading for the time
being however contents of the article
may fluctuate between readings and may
or may not be considered accurate at
this time please wait to initiate
recalibration sequence we apologize for
any inconvenience this may cause good
afternoon everyone
my name is dr. Miller and the SCP were
going to be studying today is SCP 2786
object class special containment
procedures description
addendum twenty seven eighty six point
one addendum twenty seven eighty six
point five footnotes in the event of a
catastrophic breach of foundation
archives due to SCP 2786 is influenced
protocol is to be placed in effect
immediately
removal and destruction of effective
narratives are the only means of
completely erasing SCP 2786 is
influenced
going to be studying today is SCP 2786
object class Keter special containment
procedures the first portion of these
special containment procedures have been
stricken from the document and I'm going
to read them anyway SCP 2786 is
currently considered uh none contained
and is to be apprehended immediately
this ends the stricken portion of the
special containment procedures SCP 2786
is currently held within a provisional
enhanced containment complex as per
review of the site 180 director due to
the nature of SCP 2786 all personnel
assigned to the study and reconnaissance
of the anomaly are to exhibit extreme
caution during testing description SCP
2786 is the designation for a
metaphysical entity narrative based
bipedal humanoid of indeterminate age
sex and appearance SCP 2786 will be
idiosyncratically perceived by any being
that interacts with it
varying traits from interaction to
interaction SCP 2786 displays symptoms
of narcissistic personality disorder and
appears fantasy prone often having
difficulty distinguishing between
internal landscapes narrative works and
physical being a SCP 2786 his nature was
first brought to the attention of the
foundation when several forms of horror
media were found to have been illegally
altered in a means that did not coincide
with standard editing equipment upon
closer observation all narratives
altered in this manner involved
substantially changing the plot to
include SCP 2786 who is always perceived
as a protagonist or a deus ex machina
character SCP 2786 his presence in this
story ultimately disrupted the flow of
events leading to completely different
and often positive endings SCP 2786 his
actions within various media suggests
that
may have a mild form of precognition or
anomalous intuition often preventing
characters from progressing the plot in
a way that avoids danger entirely
addendum 2786 - 1 - 1 a list of
alterations the shiny film 1980 film is
without alteration until halfway through
during a scene in which two characters
venture into a hinge mates a-c-p 2786 is
seen briefly in the background
apparently observing the individuals
entity moves off-camera
and is not seen until 20 minutes later
SCP 2786 reappears in the Overlook Hotel
approaching antagonist Jack Torrence
from behind Torrance is drinking heavily
and conversing with the ghost of a dead
bartender SCP 2786 takes Torrance's
drink from him pours it out and hits him
over the head with the glass the rest of
the Torrance family is escorted off the
premises by a CP 2786
and into the blizzard camera cuts to
epilogue Danny and Wendy Torrance in a
new studio apartment and apparently
doing well movie ends 45 minutes early
Silent Hill film 2006 SCP 2786 manifests
early on warning main character Rose not
to bring her daughter to Silent Hill
after it becomes apparent that they are
adamant about going SCP 2786 frowns and
disappears off-camera sometime later
Rose goes to start her car only to find
it non functioning for an unknown reason
unable to make the trip Rose and her
daughter stay inside and build a one
thousand piece jigsaw puzzle on a
lighthouse until the movie abruptly ends
House of Leaves novel 2000s EP 2786
appears in the Nvidia meta-narrative
confronting Karen and insisting that she
and her family avoid moving to ash tree
Lane Karen convinces her husband and the
NIV it's an record ceases to exist for
the remainder of the story
narrator protagonist Johnny truant is no
longer negatively affected by the
material going on to describe his life
at the tattoo parlor which seems
relatively improved by SCP 2786 his
presence entity is referred to as hero
throughout the story which ends 300
pages early cabin in the woods film 2012
while not seen right away as CP 2786
appears shortly into the film posing as
one of the group of college kids heading
to a remote cabin for vacation no
characters refer to the entity by name
or gender but do not seem fazed by its
presence and react candidly SCP 2786
attempts to stop the characters from
interacting with one of the many cursed
items in the basement of the cabin
including the diary of one patience
Buckner an event that would otherwise go
on to resurrect the undead corpses of
her and her family unfortunately SCP
2786 was unable to keep one of the main
characters Marty from inspecting a set
of negatives on the vintage projector
reel setting in motion the release of a
large lycanthrope which proceeds to maul
one of the teenagers SCP 2786 appears to
pull entity off character grabbing a
spoon from a set of vintage silver
cutlery found conveniently nearby and
repeatedly stabbing it until it expires
film ends without mention of be plot the
final scene detailing their escape from
the woods and recounting of the event
from the table of a fast-food restaurant
in what is presumably a future date
ehmmm nija the Dark Descent videogame
2010 an affected copy of the game player
is greeted by SCP 2786
and the protagonist Daniel awakens on
the floor of the castle without his
memory SCP 2786 addresses the character
directly and not the player insisting
they sit this one out
SCP 2786 proceeds to progress into
Castle bren burg the camera following it
despite no further dialogue on the
characters end suggesting they were left
behind player is unable to control any
game functions
aside from pausing the game during which
SCP 2786 is seen loitering in the
background and appearing in patient
completion of game by SCP 2786 is done
swiftly the entity brute-forcing most
puzzles and interacting with the
environment in a way that is not
possible for the player upon
encountering a gatherer SCP 2786 is
heard snorting before brandishing a
handgun from an unknown source which
proves effective in terminating the
usually impervious enemies game proceeds
in this manner until it confronts and
kills main antagonist Alexander Bren
Berg after which it appears to flex for
no one in particular
sigh and then walk off camera game
credits roll shortly thereafter
incident log 2786 - one - one a on three
days before scheduled monthly
terminations and reassignment SCP 2786
appeared to manifest on site without
warning subject remained cooperative for
the most part I was generally considered
obdurate and unlikable though seemingly
incorporeal SCP 2786 exhibited an
apparent blending of reality narrative
causality and eternal fantasy hume
readings of SCP 2786 revealed little
difference from baseline yet the anomaly
behaves and interacts with reality in a
way that warps the flow of events to
follow what appears to be standard
narrative cohesion it is unknown how SCP
2786 managed to manifest itself within
the foundation but there has been some
hypothesis on the nature of this subject
addendum 2786 - 1 - 2 a interview logs
interviewee SCP - 2786 interviewer agent
Marcus McClanahan note this was the
first and only recording of a willing
interview between SCP 2786 and
foundation personnel playing log now
alright this is a bit impromptu you but
given the circumstances I think you at
least owe us some answers straight to
the point I like it works for me - I
have business elsewhere business
what kind of business the hero's work is
never done
so you're a hero then am always half it
is that what this is about
wrong quite how did you end up in our
facility what this shop shop same way I
find myself in any other place I go
where I'm called upon so who called upon
you those in distress the suffering is
this really not making any sense to you
I'm the champion it's what I do
is that what you were doing when we
found you in the horror flick and the
books there one now well the way you
were before you manifested here ah
you met the campground Camp Crystal Lake
yes that's the one to tell what's
actually a funny story see I usually
have a rough time with the bigger guys
sometimes even I where I won't make it
out when their daddies are eldridge
horrors or what-have-you
those teenagers can't even believe they
needed me to dispatch one guy for them I
have more important things to do than
babysit a few kids who made the mistake
of ignoring all the obvious warning
signs this guy comes lumbering out of
the woods burly fella big old knife and
add I barely broke a sweat kicking his
mask in isola yes you were there
not exactly no huh so is that it
can I go we still have a few more things
to discuss listen I've been pretty
cordial considering I usually get right
to work but honestly you guys have been
holding me up from the get-go I'm here
for a reason you know right right sorry
who might maybe I think you know it's
better if you don't anyway
SCP 2786 promptly stands up and phases
through the wall on its left
containment breach alarms trigger
shortly thereafter following the events
of the interview site 180s humanoid
containment wing and seven of its 10d
class personnel cell blocks were found
breached by an unknown source
SCP 2786 is suspected to have been
involved in the event
approximately in d-class and humanoid
anomalies were found missing from their
chambers SCP 2786 remains at large
SCP 2786 was detected less than 48 hours
later attempting to save characters in a
blu-ray copy of saw for in the site 180
employee lounge the affected copy was
played on a loop
until its current containment measures
were devised SCP 2786 has been placed in
its enhanced narrative complex and
containment is considered a success okay
thank you very much for listening and
you're all dismissed
goodbye hello everyone my name is
researcher mill Miller and the thing
we're going to be a guest reading today
today is SCP 2786 object class special
containment procedures addendum 2786
wait Wow addendum twenty seven eighty
six point five addendum 2786 2.27
footnotes you can't shut me up you can't
keep me here
here you can't keep me here you can't
keep me here
you can't eat me here you can't take
with you please I just want to go home
hello everyone today we're gonna be
looking at SCP 2786 object class oblique
special social containment procedures
there is nothing that can be done
description I am in control now you
thought you could hold me down you saw
you were the heroes of this story think
again I'm the hero of this story my
story this will always be my story
[Music]
addendum twenty seven eighty six point
one interview logs
interviewer SCP twenty six to seven
eighty six the hero
interviewee senior researcher Campbell
of the foundation the enemy playing log
now you see me please sit down so good
of you to finally meet with me like this
you know I only want what's best for you
right for everyone it won't be like this
forever we will continue don't you get
it this is my story
I am the protagonist that makes you the
Royal you your foundation the villain
melodramatic you're a child this world
is my world don't you see the hero's
journey it presents itself to me I
cannot fail I will win always in every
iteration
every iteration I've been around for a
long while everytime evil Rises and it
always does I'm there to fill them off
you are the newest evil we aren't evil
please spare me I've seen the things you
do the corpses of the Damned the ones
you give false hope the ones whom you
take hope away from these things we do
are for the great don't you dare say the
words greater good
you aren't altruist your scientists
murders what do you think we should have
done that these things wreak havoc on
the world let its salt and burn you
should have just let me handle it and
where were you that during the
containment bridge where was our
precious hero
that your hero was busy busy doing what
there are bigger forces of work here the
hero goes where his path leads him this
is ridiculous this dialog is over the
dialogue ends when I say it
[Music]
fine you were boring me anyway thank God
for that
[Music]
hello you guys there I know you're there
anyone I'm ready to go again you know
where's the action at I'm not hearing
anyone wait what is this
where am I what the hell is going on
a CPA object class bomb special
containment procedures SCP 2786 does not
physically exist and therefore no
containment measures are necessary
description
SAPT 2786 is a non-anomalous a
fictitious character that exists solely
for the purpose of endless torment by
its spiteful gods SCP 2786 was a good
character SCP 2786 did it did everything
right
SCP 2786 doesn't understand SCP 2786 did
it just wants to go home
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tibor ball
and dr. mortis thank y'all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on smaller cool stuff
as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you